The Joe Rogan Experience
that Chevron on the 405 in Santa Monica
doc I almost got [__] I almost got
killed
I was I never get gas
like late because like you're a Sitting
Duck at a gas station yeah you're a
Sitting Duck yeah if someone's waiting
for you right they're gonna get you and
I never get gas later tonight it's
[__] dangerous especially the last
couple years and this is about a year
and a half ago or something and um I get
in my car we're jamming like after class
we always Jam like the whole front area
the whole front of my school we closed
during the scandemic we never opened it
it's you have to come through the back
it's hard to find my school right or a
private gym I don't want anybody walking
in so the whole front area I got a piano
and
and we just jammed we were jamming all
night now it's [__] like 12 30. time
to go home I turn on my truck and
you don't want to get gas in downtown in
midnight so I'm like how far am I going
to make it so I get on the pan and I'm
going West on the 10 and I'm gonna go up
the 405. I'm like am I gonna make it am
I gonna make it and then I got North on
the 405 the lights on I'm like [__] it
let me just get off on Santa Monica got
off on Santa Monica
and then you make a left and you go
under the freeway and the Chevrons and
I'm pulling up to it the guy the gas
station
close but
but pull up and I and I drive in and I
see two dudes with hoodies on holding
like bags like 20 yards away from me as
I pull in as I'm pulling in and you know
you know when you get you know when you
when you get a new car it takes you
forever to figure out how to lock the
door when you come in you're like turn
the key and then boom it takes you a
while like you had to rent a car but
after you have a car for like five years
you know what I mean you're getting
right you know what I mean but at first
it's like you're trying to learn that
[__] and how to lock it and all that so
I always practice when I get in my car I
always as soon as I shut the door lock
as soon as I shut the door lock but when
you have a new car you you have to it
takes a couple seconds until it becomes
muscle memory but
I had my truck dude I got that [__] down
so I get I drive up and I'm looking at
these two guys facing away from me with
a hoodie on and they go they're just
standing they're walking in like the gas
station that's closed and away from me
I'm like
but then I'm like
I'm just sitting there and I park I'm
like [__] it okay let me put gas I open
the door and as soon as I open the door
and I walk out this dude pops up boom
right in front of my car and starts
walking he's got a mask on he comes up
right in front of my truck dude I jumped
in and we're pressing around drove away
he goes I'm gonna wash your windows man
and I'm like [__] you and I drove away
dog and dude if they would have just
waited until I started building because
I was kicking I was keeping my eyes on
the two guys over there I was keeping
miles and I was going to come out and
pump and just and then this dude right
in front of my truck pops up boom and he
comes around dude I jumped in dude
boom bam drove away and he had a mask on
and he said it's gonna wash your windows
I'm like where's your [__] screechee
dude and I drove away and I barely made
it to another gas station up on like a
Moraga or whatever like by Sunset yeah
yeah dude they almost had me dog they
almost [__] had me Jesus if you
should never ever drive at night you
know what then I wonder I thought dude I
didn't sleep that night I didn't sleep
that night and I'm like and I swear to
God I felt like
okay I have a purpose in life because I
should have been dead right there